in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Adam is
with us hi Adam how are you great how
are you welcome welcome where're you
from Dallas Texas very cool and welcome
good to have you in Nashville and how
much have you paid off
$40,000 and 20 months good the majority
about 26,000 in the last two months
Wow that's a slam what so what's your
average income during that 20 months
about $50,000 a year okay cool so what
happened the last two months it calls
that huge acceleration I decided to just
pay it all off I had $15,000 in the bank
and I was just holding off paying it off
and I just decided to go at it what
tripped the switch that called you to go
at it all the sudden my alt said he
wouldn't let me invest in a Roth without
paying off my debt first good guy
they're teaching to do the proper stuff
well done you need a good oh you need to
be out of debt you need to have a good
emergency fund in place and then you
need to start your Roth that's good very
cool so what happened 20 months ago that
puts you on this whole course of getting
out of debt so that you can start
investing well it started with my sister
she offered me and a couple of my
brothers an opportunity to make $50 if
we read the financial or complete total
monomi
Total Money Makeover really and yeah and
I was the first one to read it so I got
$50 ah and so she didn't pay everybody
fifty the first one yeah just it's like
a race yeah okay all right yeah that's
funny so how old are you I'm 25 how old
is she
37 okay so shear and how many little
brothers does she have three little
brothers okay so she threw out to the
three little brothers and said first one
to read the book gets 50 bucks that's
pretty cool good for her yeah good for
her so that got you but then once you
got the $50 you got more than that
because you looked at it and said I got
to do something different
yep yep okay so what was the process you
used to get out of debt then setting the
goal was the biggest thing for me so
that Roth IRA so I was kind of playing
around with it paying off a little
here and there during mostly 20 months
and then once I had that goal to fund my
Roth for 2015 so I had to get it all
paid off and fund my emergency fund by
April that kind of gave me the kick in
the pants to get it all done okay very
cool push it over what kind of debt was
the forty thousand thirty thousand
dollars of student loans and $10,000 on
a Corvette oh okay
you still got the Vette yep oh yeah good
for you which model c5 okay nice car
nice car very good okay a lot of fun
well you're in good shape man completely
debt-free make a fifty thousand a year
you're single yep okay and completely
paid off everything now you finish your
emergency fund and then you get on and
start your investing so single 25 year
old guys out there listening tell them
what you did to get out of debt what are
the keys what's the secret to get out of
that I just focused intensity keeping
the budget like you say pretty much just
broken record of everyone what everyone
else says on here and I mean the one key
thing that I did that was the toughest
thing was paying off the debt without
having payments due so I paid off all
the student loans without a payment
being due and also interest wasn't even
accruing so that was the toughest thing
just paying it off even though you know
there's no interest and no payments due
but I just wanted to get it out of the
way there you go
well you're exactly right because
there's eventually gonna be interest in
payments due yeah it's not like it's
going away
yeah so you solved the problem before
it's a problem yeah very well done good
for you way to go way to go Adam good
job man all right Adam from Dallas Texas
$40,000 paid off in 20 months making 58
years all because his sister challenged
him with $50.00 to read a book count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one I'm debt free
there you go that's how you do it
excellent excellent excellent that's how
you do it man hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the
dayroom the channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you